yeah Manik SATA jr. can be quite
confusing at times plenty of terms
including well let's start with this
very obvious one their withdrawal
agreement you'll have heard about that
that's the Prime Minister's a greed deal
with the EU on the terms of the UK's
departure it covers how much money the
UK should pay the EU as a settlement
transition period citizens rights and of
course the sticking point the so-called
backstop no that's our next term the
backstop is right ariza make plans to
avoid a hard border between the Republic
of Ireland and Northern Ireland when the
UK leaves the EU their proposal in
withdrawal agreement is for the EU in
the whole of the UK to enter a temporary
single customs territory until a
permanent solution can be fine but
Northern Ireland would also have to
follow some other EU rules that's why
some people have a problem with it so an
event of that being the sticking point
no deal means that the UK will leave the
EU with no agreements in place for what
the relationship would would look like
in the future the UK would become a
what's known as a third country to the
EU and Connor's would be governed by
World Trade Organization rules WTO
you'll heard about that now each member
of the WTO has a list of taxes on
imports and limits on the number of
goods that they apply to other countries
as part of the EU the UK trades with
countries like the u.s. Brazil China
Australia on WTO terms however most big
economies also have a series of
bilateral agreements with the EU as well
as those WTO rules so that's why people
are looking for other solutions
including a Norway style deal now this
would mean the UK becoming a member of
the European Economic Area the EEA and
after the European free trade
association of which Norway Iceland
Liechtenstein and Switzerland are
members it would mean full access to the
single market and very limited barriers
to trade with the EU but Norway
contributes to the EU budget and
therefore has to abide by many of the EU
rules so that's why others prefer a
Canada style Dioner canada's free trade
deal with the EU is called the
comprehensive economic and trade
agreement and means that most important
goods are not taxed there are however
some additional customs checks Canada
doesn't pay until you use budget and
there is no free movement
still some people in favor of leaving
the EU would like the benefits of a
Canada deal plus greater access to the
EU and its financial institutions and
fewer restrictions on things like food
production to avoid the need for border
checks clear